five
big name college football players have
already opted out
of the 2020 season the ncaa earlier this
week said look anybody who opts out
still has their scholarship these guys
are opting out though
to commence their preparations for the
2021 draft
i've heard plenty of talk about agents
trying to get guys to go ahead and opt
out promises of paying for their
training
now through the scouting combine i think
guys look at this season and realize
that that whatever they do number one
they're taking a risk
that is over and above what they
ordinarily take as they're on the brink
of getting the nfl
but whatever they do it's gonna have
this weird kind of vague asterisk
applied to it no one's really going to
know what to make of this college
football season
does it make sense to even do it and the
guys who can be
confident the problem is sharing there's
more guys who are who are unreasonably
confident that they're going to be top
picks
then there are guys who should be
reasonably confident so that's the
problem you're gonna have guys opting
out who think they're gonna be first
rounders and they may not be drafted at
all
but uh i i feel like as we get closer
and closer to teams opening camp we're
gonna have more and more of these
players who opt out because for them
they're not giving up any money they're
trying to preserve their ability to get
their money in the nfl
yeah no question about it mike and we
saw the pac-12 had conference calls and
and threatened to sit out and the sec
has had
conference calls with its players who
has have expressed concerns about coven
19 and some of the protocols
so i do think we're going to see more
players and more big-name players than
we did in the nfl opt-out we did see in
the nfl some
big name opt-outs but in college
football i'm not going to be surprised
if quarterbacks running backs receivers
you know the skill position players and
we've already seen it a couple of those
but if they opt out and and they they
don't really have much to play for
if they have an nfl career and that they
they are getting prepared for the nfl to
go and make money and and this is just
that stepping stone and i think
college football as as you've said
repeatedly has to be very careful with
that line that
quote-unquote student athlete thing with
how they handle covid and whether
there's even going to be a season i
think there's a huge question now
more than in the nfl if they're going to
play this season and we're
seeing it with multiple uh division two
division three's already shut down the
big sky conference
looks like it's headed toward not
playing at least in the fall and and
we've seen it multiple times and so i'm
not confident that the power five
schools are gonna play either and i
think some of these players
are just gonna sit out start training
and get ready for the draft in 2021
the chase for the money is what's
keeping division one hopes alive even if
they ultimately do crumble if a guy like
trevor lawrence opts out that could open
the floodgates and
one last point look the ncaa's got its
hands full right now
and i'm not accusing anyone of anything
but we know how it works in college
football it wouldn't surprise me at all
to learn that money was changing hands
under the table to keep some of these
guys from opting
out because for the schools who can oh
you caught us hey we're trying to hold a
team together here in a pandemic
oh well what are you going to do about
it i mean again the ncaa may not even
try to
detect it at this point they've got too
many other things to worry about all
right
let's take a break coming up we're gonna
have a hypothetical exercise
that is premised on if the world ends
today and it very well
could it's not very funny which current
players
in the nfl would make it to the hall of
fame which obviously wouldn't exist
because the world will have
ended we get that but we're still going
to have the conversation when pft live
continues right
you